I'm going to kill the Queen I see a
darkness in you and in that darkness
eyes staring back at me brown eyes blue
eyes green eyes
eyes you'll shut forever
we will meet again hey everybody its
charlie so a bunch of you were
requesting me do a video on Arya Stark
for season eight because Maisie Williams
just wrapped on Game of Thrones she
finished filming her last episode and
made this very bloody Instagram post
that was kind of fun but also teasing a
lot of things even Lena Headey jumped on
it to because she said she was the last
woman standing so people are like wait a
minute what does this mean so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there'll
be a whole bunch of season 8 stuff
coming later this year and there's a new
round of that 4k blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so first things first the actual
post Maisie Williams says goodbye
Belfast goodbye Arya goodbye Game of
Thrones what a joy I've had here's to
the adventures to come and then just
like a litany of hashtags last woman
standing
barely like she barely crawled away I'm
asleep for four years just kidding I
don't sleep then Lena Headey jumped on
the post calling her a queen saying she
was amazing with all these emojis so
everybody put your tinfoil hats on of
course there's some meaning that we can
drop in this like the clips that I put
at the beginning of this are important
things that were yet to come for Arya
she hasn't been reunited with Melisandre
yet / episode 4 from season 7 her list
still exists it's still in her mind it's
just that she's doing other things right
now like her reunion with her family is
more important at the moment that's why
she went back when she heard that Jon
Snow had taken back Winterfell playa
headin King's Landing
why that says he's Quinlin I thought you
been in the Winterfell bed
what Jon Snow came down from Castle
black of the Wilding army and wonder
batter the bastards
he's killing off now
you're lying she was going back to see
John like obviously she probably cares
about Sansa now - there's the Wolfpack
they turned that into a big teaser - so
if he Turner's dialogue from those first
couple of teasers for Season seven the
lone wolf dies but the pack survives but
the list still exists and she has the
Valyrian dagger now which implies that
she'll have some special kills in
addition to all the White Walkers and
any theories that you have about who
she's going to kill during the battle
with the knight king's army I thought
you might go to King's Landing so did I
why would you go back there so she's on
her list of names was on your list so
we'll circle back around to Cersei in a
second but if she says she's the last
woman standing regardless of how you
feel about the Sansa character yes it's
totally possible that Sansa dies if Arya
is the last woman standing it implies
that Sansa dies earlier in the season
and Arya makes it to the end I think the
idea is is that they're getting ready to
completely shut down production and
principal photography they're doing
special effect shots right now at King's
Landing so that'll be the last big
battle that they have but they still
have the first big battle with the night
Kings army which I believe will be
episode three up at Winterfell we can
call that the third Battle of Winterfell
just add it to the list of possibilities
that Sansa dies during that big battle
now it's totally possible that she also
makes it to the final episode and just
finished filming her scenes before
Maisie Williams because sophie turner
said her goodbyes to the series a couple
weeks ago so she's been wrapped for a
while and Lena Headey has been looking
like she's been on vacation for a while
- so whatever final scenes do you think
sir she is going to have it seems like
she may have already filmed them but
just remember that there will be
reshoots later this year the only stuff
that I'm expecting them to do ratios for
are like characters talking to each
other like they're editing season 8
right now because they film most of the
episodes so once they start editing
things they find things are missing and
then they'll call the actors back like
hey Arya we need to scene with you
talking to Jon Snow referencing this
particular thing so that this later
scene makes sense that's the kind of
stuff that you can magic up on the fly
like you just have two actors talking
together in a dimly lit hallway you
can't really do giant reshoots for big
battle scenes like this
the special-effects stuff like the
Dragons battling at King's Landing the
Dragons battling at Winterfell
all of that stuff will be done
relatively soon because it'll take them
a lot longer to finish the special
effects for season 8 than it did for
season 7
so yes it's totally possible that even
though most of the actors are rapping
right now that like way later this year
they reassemble a couple people to film
scenes privately and bury that in
reshoot like if there's a secret final
scene that they're waiting to the very
last minute to film behind closed doors
they can just do that when they bring
people back to do reshoots so it's like
oh everybody's coming back to Belfast so
it's not like just Jon Snow is coming
back or just Daenerys is coming back to
film a scene or just Cersei Jaime and
Arya are mysteriously coming back to
film a scene together why would they do
that next big theory if she's the last
woman standing it also implies that
Cersei is no longer standing now but
only Stokes the tinfoil flames that Lena
Headey jumped in on her post here
praising her as the true queen like
right now Cersei and Daenerys are Queen
it would take a long list it goes a
really long list for Arya to jump in the
line of succession because right now the
only stark that's in line for the throne
is John and that's because he's half
Targaryen the other big queen is
Daenerys so I know a lot of people have
theories about what's going to happen to
her I've already done many videos about
why they're foreshadowing her having a
baby with Jon Snow so you have to take a
lot of this last woman standing with the
grain of salt and assumed that they
don't film scenes in chronological order
so whatever her final scene was it could
have been a flash-forward or she could
have filmed her last chronological scene
like the last moment as she appears in
the finale a long time ago in this final
scene that she just filmed was just the
last one that they had on their list and
it takes place earlier in the timeline
but even though I said this theory was
crazy a little while ago just based on
the way things are shaping up in the
fact that sophie Turner said that the
finale is wildly unpredictable which i
think means a couple things that it's
not gonna be like the Song of Ice and
Fire George are Martin ending that he
intended and it's also going to be
twistier
than we expect like you always expect
big twists in Game of Thrones episodes
but it sounds like it's gonna be extra
twisty in the finale like oh my god I
never thought that this would happen so
there are a couple theories that I put
back on my list of possibilities you
have to acknowledge now that our
wearing Jamie's face killing Cersei as
the valonqar Jaime is the younger
brother so I really just hope that he
would be the one to kill Cersei but you
know you just add an extra layer deep on
that theory the valonqar is a Valyrian
prophecy in high Valyrian is a
gender-neutral language meaning it could
be younger brother or younger sister in
Aria is a younger sister so she could be
the valonqar but it would be very poetic
to have Jaime kill Cersei but even more
so in twisty like Sophie Turner's
talking about to have Jaime die in the
arms of someone he loves but then along
comes Aria taking his face and wearing
it to kill Cersei after that but
remember that is a hardcore tinfoil
theory so it's relatively low on my list
of possibilities I think already his
ending will be a little more
straightforward but yes I do think that
she will wear people's faces during
season eight it would be weird for them
to do it so much during season seven and
then not have her do it during season
eight for some big twist but what about
the Melisandre prophecy she said that
she would see her again and we know that
Melisandre is coming back to help out it
seems like she'll be around for the
final battle when they're attacking
King's Landing so I also want to believe
that if Melisandre is the one that's
going to die remember she's hundreds of
years old so she believed that she's
immortal functionally I think the Arya
would be the one to do it
Arya says that she's the last woman
standing with blood all over her shoes
if you're wondering why she's wearing
tennis shoes here it's either because
the scene that she was filming didn't
require them to shoot from the waist
down so she could wear whatever shoes
she wanted or she was wearing the
correct boots like wearing
period-specific Game of Thrones clothing
got really bloody on her face and then
when she changed out of those boots
maybe some of the blood dripped on to
those shoes just remember that they
could be trolling us a little bit Maisie
Williams has done that in the past and
there could be other scenes that the
actors are lying about that they'll be
filming later this year behind closed
doors we'll probably get those first
teasers before the end of the year
obviously there's gonna be some crazy
special effects it'll take them a long
time to finish so we don't think the
first full trailer will drop till early
next year but they'll be Game of Thrones
book stuff happening later this year so
just leave all your video requests in
the comments below but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Conor
Meacham please private message
so I can get your contact details click
here for more new season 8 and click
here for my ant-man in the wasp
post-credit scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight